-So, I heard you talk about this
on "Howard Stern,"
and it's really a cool story
which is that you became
pen pals with Donald Trump's
former lawyer, Michael Cohen
and to the point
that you actually
went and visited him in prison
-Yes, I did, in federal prison
-So, how did it start?
How did the
pen-pal nature start?
-Well, you know, he sounds
like he's one of my brothers
Excuse me.
[ Sneezes ]
No COVID. I swear, no COVID.
I'll give that again
in case you want to edit it.
He sounds like he's somebody
from my neighborhood,
Michael Cohen.
You know, every time
I heard him talk, I'm like
"What is he?
From the next town over
on Long Island?"
Like, he seemed very familia
to me the whole time
that I knew of his existence
which was during
that whole period when Trump
was attacking me on,
you know, a daily basis.
And I knew, from knowing
a little about
the Trump Organization
and how it all worked,
that it was him who did it
It wasn't Donald Trump
sitting there
calling David Pecker and,
you know, Donald Trump
making all the plans of how they
were going to best attack me
I knew that it was him,
so I kind of looked at him
with fascination the whole tim
that I was involved
in any way with Trump.
And then when
Trump got impeached,
I kept thinking about him.
I'm like, "Imagine that
he gets impeached,
he's in The White House,
and the guy that told you
to do all this,
you're sitting in jail,
and he's sitting in
The White House.
How does that feel?"
So I wrote him a letter
and I put a little picture
of myself with
my daughter in there,
'cause I didn't know if he'd
believe that it was me, right?
It was a handwritten letter.
And about a week later,
I get an e-mail from him.
Now, I had no idea
that they were
allowed to use e-mail,
prisoners.
Did you know that?
-I wouldn't have known that.
-I didn't know that either
So, I was waiting for, you know,
mail delivered by the mailman,
and it was an e-mail.
And I was like,
"They're giving them e-mail?
And he was very kind.
He said that he was shocke
that I wrote him
and that he apologized and
he was sorry for what he did
And a lot of people
had told him that I was
a good person,
and he felt so bad.
And, so, then I wrote him back
and we started sort of
writing, you know?
And after a few months
of that, he said,
"Would you ever come
and visit me?
I'd like to apologize
to your face, you know?
And I'd like to
talk to you one-on-one,"
which you really
can't do in a prison
because there's so many people
And, so, I go there
and I get into this --
what looks like
a college campus.
Like, it has no guard gates.
It has no towers.
-So he's in a very nice jail
-He's in what I believe they
call Camp Cupcake.
And I walked in,
and there he was.
And he looked pretty good,
I have to say.
And we sat and we talked.
And next to me was a guy,
friend of Michael's in prison.
And he said, "Oh, Rosie, don't
you remember me?"
And I was like,
"Give me a hint?"
And he said,
"We sat next to each other
at Liza Minnelli's
60th birthday party."
I was like, "What?"
And he was apparently
a friend of Liza's
who did some AIDS charity
and then got caught
or, you know, doing --
And he's been in there for -
Like, since that birthday party,
he's been in jail.
-So you knew multiple people
when you went to visit
Michael Cohen.
-I knew that guy,
and then another guy
came over to me and said,
"My kid goes to school
with your daughter."
-Fantastic.
-I was like, "Wow."
-Did you --
Do you feel as though --
You know, obviously,
he apologized to you,
Michael Cohen.
He seems like someone
who appreciates
what he did wrong
and, in general,
seems to be trying to be
a better person.
Is that the bounce you got off
him when you spoke to him?
-That's completely
what I got off him.
And a great thing he told me
was that the whole time
he worked for Trump --
He had already made his mone
on his own, and the whole time
that he worked for Trump,
his wife and kids kept saying,
"You got to quit that job.
You got to quit that job."
The whole time he worked there
And he got tears in his eyes
and he said,
"I just wish I'd listened
to my wife and kids.
If I had listened to my
wife and kids,
I wouldn't be here
in this position, you know?"
-I can imagine
when this is over,
one of the first things you will
do is go see a Broadway show
Is that is an accurate guess
-That is totally accurate.
I can't wait.
That's my big --
You know, I don't know
how long it's gonna take,
because those seats
are so cramped together
and they're a lot of money
for a ticket.
And I'm worried about what
the economy --
all these unemployed people.
It's going to be a tough
road after we're out of this
the viral part of it,
when we get back to
the just living, you know?
-You did a reboot of your show
to raise money
for The Actors Fund.
You raised over a
half-a-million dollars.
That was an incredible gesture
Is there a way for people,
if they want to
make a contribution to that,
to still do it now?
-Yeah, The Actors Fund is great.
It serves all actors and peopl
in the industry of theater
like, you know,
stagehands from Minnesota
or people in a touring company
Like, and it really doesn'
just encompass actors,
because I had some people say,
"Oh, you rich actors are takin
care of each other."
No, that's not what
The Actors Fund does.
So, you can go to
theactorsfund.org
and look it up
and see what they do.
And they have
a donate button there, too
to help people get through this.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
I can't wait to watch
on Sunday night.
And it's always a pleasure
Rosie O'Donnell, everyone.
-Thanks, Seth.
Good to see you.
-Alright, be well.